realmente china si tiene o puede ejercer
el poder sobre rusia para tratar de
llevarlo a la mesa y que no siga esta
escala además de china también quiero
hablar de otro aliado que s belarús pues
evidentemente también presta su
territorio el régimen de lukashenko para
que rusia pues se acerque aún más a
occidente y pues puede hacer
absolutamente todo tipo de maniobras
militares en ese territorio entonces
hablemos pues esa pregunta que le hice
sobre chinas y que realmente tienen
influencia sobre rusia para poder
sentarnos en la mesa y luego de belarús
el papel de además lukachenko
bueno efectivamente
influencia hace poco tiempo estuvo en
china de los juegos olímpicos de
invierno
de modo que ahí hay un vínculo que
particularmente anuncia quisiera
reforzar porque también les permitiría
reforzar un proyecto que ya tiene unos
años que es la unión euroasiática y el
contrapeso a las potencias europeas hay
que ver hasta hasta donde efectivamente
china quisiera involucrarse en este
conflicto en conflicto que pase lo que
pase este puede sacar una gran tajada
respecto de la luz y ha funcionado está
funcionando como viene funcionando desde
hace varios años con un aliado este
informal de de rusia de hecho antes del
conflicto tropas rusas apostaron en
dentro del territorio
de la luz de modo que no debemos esperar
nada sorpresivo respecto de la conducta
de este país que va a apoyar lo que
decida rusia porque está al menos
geopolíticamente en una gran alianza con
con ese país
profesor ya para ir finalizando pues en
nuestra conversación y su análisis le
digo entonces
conclusiones hacia hacia dónde podemos
mirar cómo están las cosas hablando de
los hechos indicamos indicar en
especulaciones qué podría pasar en
digamos en los próximos minutos en las
próximas horas
bueno como viene sucediendo desde
diciembre del año pasado es un conflicto
que hay que estar atento minuto a minuto
que va cambiando día a día y cualquier
evento que suceda no nos tiene que
llevar a hacer pronósticos de medidos
porque como venimos viendo en la
escalada del conflicto cualquier
pronóstico o cualquier interpretación se
puede derrumbar en cuestión de minutos
hace unas semanas estábamos apelando a
una salida diplomática y hoy estamos
hablando no solamente del reconocimiento
de la república separatista sino también
ya directamente del ataque militar de
rusia a ucrania de modo que tenemos que
estar atento a lo que vaya sucediendo
minutos a minutos y en función de eso
poder establecer qué es lo que sucede o
cómo se va a resolver el conflicto que
lo que espera a todo el mundo es que
precisamente no escalen y no termine
desembocando en un enfrentamiento mayor
que involucre a otros países y otro tipo
de momento como es el armamento nuclear